les nous sommes avec nicolas klain
spécialiste de l'espagne contemporaine
bonsoir nicolas klain merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france l'espagne
qui a donc annoncé fermer ses frontières
ce soir minuit une bonne chose selon
vous c'était sans doute inévitable de
toute façon ça faisait plusieurs jours
que cette idée s'impose et lentement
dans les esprits
donc les frontières terrestres de toute
façon c'est le minimum puisque pour le
moment il n'y a pas encore de décision
sur l'aéroportuaire et le maritime mais
ça semblait inévitable à ccc manifeste
pourquoi c'est une décision selon vont
qui intervient maintenant ce que ce
n'est pas tardif est le gouvernement
aurait peut-être pu prendre cette
décision avant de toute façon le
gouvernement espagnol de pedro sanchez a
réagi très tardivement même bien avant
cette annonce de la fermeture des
frontières terrestres
il y a encore un peu plus d'une semaine
le dimanche 8 mars
il incitait les gens à venir manifester
dans les rues pour la journée mondiale
des droits des femmes alors qu' il y
avait des dd fait très fort est
fortement déconseillé à la fois par
l'union européenne et par les autorités
scientifiques espagnols que beaucoup de
partis de personnalités demandé que
c'est manifestation soit déprogrammé et
globalement le gouvernement de pedro
sanchez a malheureusement est très très
tardive dans ses réponses alors depuis
quelques jours on voit un emballement et
une radicalisation des mesures qui sont
prises mais elles n'arrivent globalement
tard ce qui explique aussi la gravité de
la situation dans le pays car
effectivement deuxième pays d'europe le
plus touché les hôpitaux sont ils
saturent et en précise qu'il est à mille
cas supplémentaires en 24 heures ça fait
plus de 8000 car en espagne telle est la
situation des hôpitaux en espagne alors
c'est très variable selon les
communautés autonomes c'est la
communauté de madrid qui est la plus
touchée mais ça n'est pas tellement
étonnant puisque c'est là la principale
porte d'entrée du pays c'est le coeur
économique et politique du pays
donc certains hôpitaux de la communauté
de madrid effectivement sont dans une
situation tendue
je pense notamment aux hôpitaux la
banlieue est comme un torero des hardos
par exemple
le où se sont déclarés les premières
grandes vagues de contagion
progressivement on va voir jusqu'à
mercredi encore de nouveaux afflux dans
les hôpitaux la la communauté de madrid
est peut-être une des rares régions
avoir réagi très rapidement
justement par comparaison du
gouvernement national de région et elle
essaie aujourd'hui de tout faire pour
habiliter de nouveaux espaces de soin
pour créer de nouveaux lits dans les
unités de soins intensifs
tout ça effectivement est tendue et
malheureusement je pense que des
hôpitaux de la région et plus largement
les hôpitaux espagnols ne sont pas
sortis d'affaires alors 46 millions
d'habitants n'ont plus le droit de
sortir de chez eux que pour des raisons
impératives comme aller travailler se
rendre à la pharmacie se faire soigner
ou acheter à manger un petit peu sans
doute ce qui va se passer en france on
attend l'explication de texte d'edouard
philippe qu'on va d'ailleurs suivre dans
quelques minutes un premier ministre qui
doit s'exprimer à 21h est ce que les les
espagnols respecte ses consignes des
choses des autorités globalement oui
bien sûr qu'il y ait toujours des des
exceptions mais globalement oui ils les
respectent
on a eu un premier bilan des amendes et
des arrestations aujourd'hui dans les
principales villes à l'encontre dès
personnes ne les a pas respectées et que
ce soit à madrid ou barcelone par
exemple ça concerne une petite centaine
ou au pire 200 individus donc c'est
marginal 1 sur des des agglomérations
qui par exemple pour madrid fait six
millions d'habitants aujourd'hui quel
est l'état d'esprit des espagnols face à
cette crise sans précédent on a vu qu
emmanuel macron appelé les français à
rester unis à ne pas céder à la panique
on a vu que nous en france quelques
accès de panique 1 ces dernières heures
des gens qui fuient et notamment la
capitale pour aller se réfugier à la
campagne de peur d'un confinement total
quel est l'état d'esprit en espagne
alors l'état d'esprit je pense qu'il est
globalement combatifs les gens confiance
non pas tellement dans leurs
responsables politiques qui en plus sur
cette crise ne l'auront globalement ne
pouvait pas donner de raison d'avoir
confiance en eux mais ils ont confiance
dans le système de santé je rappelle
toujours
malgré cette crise l'espagne à un des
meilleurs systèmes de santé au monde qui
est régulièrement classé dans les
meilleurs au monde par toute une série
de fondation et d'organismes qu'ils ont
confiance dans leur système de santé
même s'ils savent que ça va être très
difficile ils ont confiance dans les
forces de l'ordre dans l'armée
maintenant effectivement il ya eu des
débordements des gens qui se sont
précipités dans les supermarchés comme
en france et aussi des madrilènes qui
sont partis la semaine dernière en
province non pas par peur d'un
confinement mais simplement parce que
ils devaient aller travailler ou qu'il
n'avait plus rien à faire dans la
capitale il faut savoir que madrid a
coupé beaucoup de gens qui sont
originaires d'autres régions de
l'espagne mais globalement on sent les
gens respectueux aujourd'hui du
confinement et combatif
je pense tous fois et ça beaucoup
d'espagnols de 10 sur les réseaux
sociaux qu une fois que la crise sera
réglé on l'espère le plus vite possible
des responsabilités politiques seront
demandés ça c'est très clair
merci beaucoup à nicolas klinger était
avec nous en direct sur rt france